dude i'm hungry yeah i'm hungry for love
man i'm uh
oh i'm a little sucker man so you don't
have any
any birthday big birthday plans and i'm
always working yeah nothing planned
i you know it's just i'm not a big
birthday guy
you're not well it's on april fool's and
so people tend to
like play pranks on me like i i happen
to be the butt of the joke
and it became unfunny after like 20
years
it's that's it's my least favorite
holiday yeah man
my least favorite birthday ever
[Applause]
my brother's fighting april 17th yeah so
i'll be in atlanta supporting him which
is what's great
look when my brother fights i fight yep
i mean not really but
yeah kind like i'm more nervous for his
fights than i say you're involved you're
you're invested i'm in that dude he's my
blood jake has been through
hell he's he's fine i love how much
support you guys have for each other
like i know of course your blood and
your brothers but you know
i feel like you guys really go to bat
for each other uh does that happen when
you hear rumors out there too
because for example you know with julia
rose she claimed he cheated on her
like do you pay attention to any of that
and how hard is it for you not to
respond
it's not hard to not respond i don't i
don't
give a [ __ ] i don't care i mean
as long as jake is doing okay like
that's what i care about i'll check in
on
um my brother because i love him uh and
i'll always have his back
no matter how dumb he makes himself look
as
he'll always have my back when i slip up
or say or do something dumb
it's what brothers do man like at the
end of the day like say what you want
i have i have one brother and and we
came from the same
the same home same parents same blood
and i
i cherish that you know and and i don't
think anything will ever get in the way
of that yeah
here's a question are both paul brothers
single right now
is that what's going on i guess that's
just the way this cookie crumbles man
is it trouble are you on the hunt for
the hunt
my eyes are open okay your eyes are are
peeled but uh
are you ready to stay single a little
bit longer or are you looking to
no a girl no i want to settle down you
do
maybe i don't know dude i don't know
what i want i'm 26
uh or about to be in two days and
i don't know it's hard love life
dating it's all so complicated so much
right now there's so much about
relationships
it's just this weird timing thing it's
just where are you at your life where
are you
uh literally in the world proximity wise
like can we is this feasible
um ish is uh
one potential candidate too young is is
another too mature right because i'm i'm
26 i'm in this limbo land where like
i chronologically i feel about like
between 30 and 35
i've just lived a lot of life but but
sometimes i'm also i still want to be a
kid i still want to like
drive down a dirt road blasted music
at my ranch and like dance on top of the
roof while the car's moving like i'm
crazy i'm pop i'm i'm complex
i love that though i mean i'm curious is
there something from your
most recent relationship that you
learned about yourself
um that you're going to apply next time
it's a great question
uh yeah yeah um so you know
they say you want to find out uh
more about yourself or what's wrong with
you getting a relationship
and yeah i mean i there's a there's a
handful of lessons but
i think the most notable one for me
is that i'm uh i'm gonna sound so
desperate dude i'm hungry yeah i'm
hungry for love man i am
uh oh i'm a little sucker man like
are you a little hopeless romantic dude
i just realized it literally i was i was
driving down the street
uh this would happen like this week and
i was thinking about
my dating and how i'm feeling and i go
oh my god i'm i'm a hopeless romantic
i'm i'm i'm i'm i'm a disaster
no come on yo it's like we need more
lovers in this world
i was never like this i don't know what
happened all of a sudden like
oh love you know it's such a such a
powerful thing and there's so many
tentacles that come with it and it's so
exciting and so scary and uh
yeah man it's not looking good for me
man no
i love this side of you so much